free at last free at last thank God
Almighty we are free at last
ladies and gentlemen please welcome your
next speaker the Reverend Robert Jones
I can't nobody can follow that Holmes oh
all right
good afternoon that is the the best
speech I've ever heard in my entire life
ever I have never heard a better speech
and now it is my turn to speak huh we
put this running water together right
you know dr. King he actually covered a
lot a lot of what I was gonna say you
know my speech is you'll find this funny
oh but speech was actually called a
vision for the future I'm not saying
that dr. King copied my speech no no no
I'm saying I'm not saying that I'm not
saying he tried to copy what's all this
- Wow
you know what no come on I'm just saying
I'm just saying the joke did I not say
it like a joke okay nope
apparently I've six more minutes let's
see a red Red Hills of Georgia he got
that out there look okay you know what
all right here here's something here's
something new
here's something brand-new okay this is
off me talking off the top of my head
here everybody how about if we let black
people enslave white people for okay you
know that sounded a lot better in my
head
so that sell that wouldn't work is it
worn is anybody else warm oh okay okay
okay here's what we gonna do is only
gonna do all right dr. King talked about
all the races coming together right
right so I want every Negro to do here
today is found the nearest white person
and give them a hug just just give him a
hug okay
no sir you're not being attacked you're
not being attacked you're being hugged
okay everybody take it easy here okay
everybody relax you know what
we don't need ten Negroes hugging one
white person okay let's just let's heal
that's the new rule not ten on one one
on ones we just take turns everything
okay everybody relax okay oh my goodness
sir she doesn't need to be defended she
doesn't need to be Betty she's okay
she's okay okay all right okay